hey guys how's it going Justine here and
this is my new TV and I am so extremely
excited about the television because I
saw this at CES this year and it was one
of those things they see a CES and you
think this is never going to come out
it's not going to be real it's too cool
it's never going to happen
and here it is sitting in my office I'm
kind of in disbelief let's get a knife
or something something sharp not too
sharp I'm currently you're waiting for
the installation person to come it's
about 6:30 in the morning got up really
early because you never know when
they're actually going to show up so
I've got to be on my guard and I got to
get this thing unboxed before they get
here cool it's an unboxing if I don't
actually do the involvement oh gosh I'm
so excited
episode welcome oh boy all my goodness
gracious I'm a little bit concerned
about this to people thing you're shy
just wait then these people come and do
this for me so here's the thing with
this TV it is so extremely thin that
it's a television that is basically
meant to only be mounted on your wall it
doesn't have a stand it's way too stingy
to stand up on its own let's see what
the accessories are installation cables
manual remote battery here's our remote
what is that not a remote some
directions since I'm not installing
somebody else is probably going to need
these so here's a bunch of the pieces
that we're using for installation screws
cables stuff I'll put this over here
what's in here ah so this is very
important this is a substantial piece of
cable now let's look inside oh wow okay
I am NOT going to be able to do this so
I don't want to break it it's so fragile
I don't think I trust myself trying to
get this out of here this is it right
here so in shock
this is this look right here now I
shouldn't I shouldn't do this I think it
wouldn't be responsible and let someone
else more responsible do this for me
this is the TV that's going to be
replaced it's actually which is the TV
for my guestroom here's another issue is
this TV even going to fit here this is a
55 inch TV and to be completely honest
with you I didn't actually do any
measurements so I'm not even sure if
it's been put on this wall
[Music]
the
I do wonder man
hisses Rudy's dress is right here
[Music]
Oh
it's officially finally fed up and I've
had so many friends over and we've all
just been sort of sitting here and odd
and there's no way that I can even
explain to you in this video what it
looks like in real life because it looks
so real it's like you're looking into a
poster it's not even on and I'm beyond
impressed I just feel like I'm not going
to be able to do it justice in this
video because I can't show you what I'm
seeing with my real eyes through this
camera like it's dinner my iPhone how
does that even work well it works
because the OLED screen is connected by
this white cable that goes into the
sound bar and the sound bar is basically
where powers the television and I've a
few my inputs where you can put your
games your TV and whatever else you want
to input into the TV into the sound bar
it's basically like magic so this setup
it's not my final setup because it's a
Lamar is actually a lot bigger than I
thought it was going to be and clearly
it does not fit on this stand I wanted
to see what it looks like in my office
before I decided to drill through the
wall because I would love to get this
cable hidden behind the wall and then
it'll go into sound bar the cable isn't
that obvious but for me I definitely
want to have it hit you so stay tuned
for a future video where I can show you
guys the final final final of my office
what the speakers just rise right out of
the sound bar and it is use like a
magical magical experience to sit here
just be like look what are you doing
let's get over there get some aside and
see like like I feel like these trees to
just be coming out and hitting me in the
eye
oh it smells so good have you compared
it to how thin it is like something no I
haven't yet which I can hair looking
hair is only can you believe it like
it's thinner than my iPhone Oh huge
figure
okay it's finally like two or three SD
cards two and a half SD card pretty
crazy
Creason there's also an extender table
so if I do mount this and then I want to
put this somewhere else
they've got that option you like it this
is loan so we're going to plug in an
attend a switch and place a Mario Kart
so the remote control also acts as like
a pointer so look point to check it out
how that employer disconnect us mostly a
Mario car it's just us all the new
velvet you'll see Val what yes wait what
yes wait why didn't you tell me I'm
telling you now okay Justin saw the DLC
it's downloading but now I wanna play
some Mario Kart and do a quick little
test to see what this feels like game on
oh yeah 200cc baby let's do it
it's so fast where am I going
hahaha Oh baby
[Music]
just disregard everything that you saw
right there a very poor performance on
my part if thing is going to look so
good on the Xbox Scorpio just being
yourself addict it's so perfect
[Music]
Bing
Oh
[Music]